from exclusive items to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Starbucks in Italy and the US
this is food
Wars our hot drinks in Italy come in
four sizes short tall Grande and venty
our hot drinks come in five sizes short
tall Grande venti and the coffee
traveler two of these like Grande and
venti are Italian words like Venti means
20 in Italian and Grande just means big
let's measure them out to
see the name translates to 20 but is not
in the US iced coffees come in four
sizes tall Grande venti and Trenta
Trenta is not available as an option for
their espresso drinks but you can get it
in stuff like cold brew or their Iced
Teas our ice coffees come in three sizes
a tall Grande and ventti let's measure
the ventti to to see if it actually is
20 oz 18 oz so again not a true vti it's
more like a dto which is like 18 we're
also going to weigh some popular food
items from Starbucks let's start with
the butter
croissant so it's a pretty big
difference to how much Italy weighs it's
a lot smaller another popular Bakery
item is the blueberry muffin let's see
what it weighs
here's everything that you find at
Starbucks in Italy that you won't find
in the US here's everything that you'll
find at a Starbucks in the US that you
won't find in Italy we know that
Starbucks is popular because of its
customization options so because of that
we're only going to look at the official
menus in the US and Italy these are the
exclusive hot drinks that you can find
at Starbucks here in Italy starting from
this tiny cup uh this one is barley
coffee in Italian we call it Cafe dorso
and it's basically an alternative to
Espresso for those people that kind of
really drink coffee it has the look of
coffee I'm not a fan of this I think you
know if because I can drink no more
coffee so but if I were not able to I
think I'll just force myself to like it
just for the you know pleasure of still
having my espresso and then we have a
vanilla latte it does smell just like
just like a cappuccino really but
obviously it's like past 11 or so so
it's like past breakfast time anyway so
cappuccinos are like a no no drink for
me I'm not so much into like drinking
milk after a certain time of the day and
then we have latte macato and then we
have this one this one is a Sal salted
Maple and caramel
latte it's just smells like sugar it's
nice yeah it does taste like fake
artificial syrup and then we got got
some teas we got Tana English breakfast
jasmine pearl hibiscus or ibiscus as we
say here and camomo and you may also be
able to find the Moroccan which in
Italian just translates into like
literally marokino it's like a tiny
cappuccino in a way there's like a bit
of coffee and a bit of milk obviously
with like its own like proper ratio and
it's named weirdly after a Moroccan
leather that has the same color that
this coffee has is like a brownish like
light brown leather that's actually very
popular here in the northern region in
Milan so here are the hot exclusive
beverages we bought today this is the
caramel apple spice juice the apple
crisp oat milk macchiato we have a
blonde vanilla latte and this is a royal
English breakfast tea we also have these
exclusive hot drinks I feel like I have
to try this caramel apple spice juice
because because it looks nothing like
juice so I'm
interested I think it's just hot apple
cider it doesn't taste bad actually that
tastes pretty good I'm going to try the
Royal English breakfast tea in honor of
hary it's not my favorite but my
preference is iced tea not hot tea so
maybe that's why and I also like them a
lot sweeter we have lots of exclusive
cold drinks here in Italy we didn't get
everything but here's what we've got
starting from a cookies and cream
Frappuccino I'm quite surprised this is
exclusive to Italy cuz I always
associate cookies and cream with the
US it has helded shape in the delivery
to me this this is a bit of a foreign
idea cuz we just have the boring
chocolate
flavor yeah like chocolate cookies nice
it's like a childhood memory here are
all the fraps that we got so we have the
chai cream this is the mocha cookie frap
this is the apple crisp frap the pumpkin
spice frap and the white mocha cream
frap I feel very compelled to try this
mocha cookie frap because it just looks
like a milkshake it looks like dessert
there's literally cookie crumbles in
it yeah it tastes like cold chocolate
milk specifically n syrup chocolate milk
an apple crisp Frappuccino sounds kind
of special to me so I really want to
taste it kind of tastes like a candle I
don't like that not at all but I tried
it the pumpkin spice wrap and the apple
crisp wrap are seasonal items so you're
not going to be able to find them year
round and then we have iced cold foam
cappuccino um we don't really have a lot
of foam here it also looks quite dark
for Cappuccino but maybe that's just
because the foam is is gone but I don't
know they keep putting hearts here but
I'm not really tempted to try this and
then we have an iced salted Maple and
caramel latte does does smell a lot
like sugar actually not even like Maple
it actually just smells like sugar and
you can see the sugar at the top I did
live in Canada for one year let's see if
it does actually taste like Maple I
don't know if I can advocate for like
Canadians out there but for what is
worth I'm going to try it there's no
Maple in there definitely no it's like
sugar not even caramel just a lot of
sugar I feel like a Canadian would never
order this but that would be another
episode of food Wars and then we have
iced chai tea o latte again quite
surprised that this is exclusive to
Italy cuz we're not so big on like chai
I don't know for some reason I really
like chai as like the tea version but
I've never really quite liked it with
milk so we have cold Brews but we also
have Nitro cold Brews which are a little
bit frothier and thicker than the
regular cold brew this is the pumpkin
cream cold brew this is the cinnamon
caramel cream Nitro cold brew and here
we have the vanilla sweet cream Nitro
cold brew I already know that I love the
pumpkin cream cold brew I kind of want
to try this cinnamon caramel
one no not for me it's a little weirdly
sweet for something that doesn't have
any milk in it I don't think let me try
this one this one's really good I really
like the vanilla sweet cream cold r that
just tastes like a really good foamy
coffee we then have this one the Very
Berry hibiscus refresher and then we
have a matcha frappe again I don't know
how this is specific to Italy because I
think the whole matcha craze has kind of
maybe spared us in a way but there's no
other place where you will find any
matcha flavoring cuz I think our green
thing is pistachio like we just don't
have space for two green things to
compete let's give it a try I've never
actually had it in a frappucino yeah
tastes like matcho just very artificial
matcho we have a bunch of other iced
coffees that you can get here they all
are and today we actually bought the
iced flat white I've had this before and
I think I really like it but I just want
to take this up again still good still
delicious it's a little milky but it's
really tasty we also have several Iced
Teas here we have the pumpkin cream chai
the matcha lemonade a peach green tea
the London Fog iced latte an iced
passion tea the frozen strawberry acai
lemonade and the Frozen mango dragon
fruit lemonade Starbucks sells these
Evolution fresh juices this one is
orange apple mango pineapple and acerola
that sounds really good I've never had
matcha and lemonade together so let's
taste
it that's actually not bad I thought I
was going to hate it it's actually
pretty good let's try the London Fog tea
latte no so candly I feel like I'm going
to keep saying that why does everything
taste a little weird today I do want to
try one of these Frozen Refreshers let's
see what this strawberry acai tastes
like it's really good it tastes like
strawberry lemonade it's not frozen
anymore but it's tasty we didn't have a
bunch of smoothies we have this innocent
blue juice then the names are actually
funny cuz they there are play play Bo
here this one is called fa blo then we
have a pink juice from innocent this one
has another playo word is like Rosa
aosa and if you're Italian watching this
yes I'm from the south cuz you can tell
by the way we pronounce our O's we then
have these tiny ones uh this juice is
mango passion fruit and apple and
another one with strawberry and banana
yeah they look very nice and natural we
have other cold drinks this one is a
kinoto and they all are from this brand
Tom Mario I've actually never heard of
it but it looks like a fancy kinoto to
me so kinoto is an Italian drink made
with Bergamot we normally just have it
from s pelino which is like a more
commercial brand does taste good it's a
bit like the Italian version of
Coca-Cola my parents generation they
were having these not Coke we then have
a red orange um we have sparkling soda
from the same brand and um we have
lemonade which looks very nice and then
we picked up also this uh it's just cold
infused water in Italian it's called
infuso Fredo and actually we got more
here are the rest of the cold drinks
here is the US only customizable drink
that we created this is a Cafe vanilla
coffee frap with half and half the cup
is lined with caramel sauce it's got
brown sugar syrup up mocha sauce and
cinnamon dolce sprinkles and also I
think some cookie crumbles there there
are some mysterious crumbles on top that
I have no idea where they came from
because I didn't ask for them but it
looks fun this is going to give me the
worst tummy ache I already
know that is the sweetest drink I think
I've ever tasted in my life it's too
much absolutely too much it is really
fun that Starbucks lets you customize
anything pretty much anything cuz this
would never have been made otherwise
there is a lot of food at Starbucks here
in Italy let's start from the Savory
options we've got your deer salmon
bagel I don't know does that have cream
cheese in it no it does look like just
salmon and some herbs some like sad
salads yeah this is also cooked salmon
and aren't you big on like smoked salmon
over there there I don't know Nico you
are in New York what do you think from a
New Yorker point of view does that look
like a good bagel no it does not but
maybe it tastes better than it looks
then we have some toasts we have ham and
cheese looks like an honest toast and
then we got the same version just with
three cheeses I'll be curious to know
which cheeses they are cuz they just say
three cheeses and then we've got baked
fuka with ham well okay first of all
this is not fuka I mean I don't know
what this is it looks great actually
looks very nice and fluffy but this is
not for capture because it just doesn't
have the shape and it's too fluffy it
just looks like bread to me yeah looks
quite nice actually like a normal
sandwich you will find it's quite
refreshing cuz I don't know when this is
going out but like the amount of burgers
and like things filled with weird sauces
I had to try for this show it's just
unbelievable and Starbucks I don't know
but like it looks looks like you really
made it in Italy you're like serving
actually Daran food so thank you and
here we have some of our exclusive
breakfast items this is The Impossible
sandwich the bacon and Grier egg bites
the bacon sausage egg wrap the bacon
goua and egg sandwich and here's the
berry Trio parfait let's take a bite of
the impossible sandwich I've had this
before and I feel like I mostly like it
it's just like a little bit weird if you
let it sit for too
long I feel like for a not real Sausage
Patty this actually tastes pretty good
I've always thought that the egg bites
were like some sort of Genius move even
though Starbucks definitely didn't
invent them my favorite are the egg
white bites these don't look edible
anymore but I'll take a
bite that's really good actually I think
it's just because I got a mouthful of
bacon but it tastes really good and then
we have a bunch of
sandwiches here we call sandwiches Trini
but it's kind of translation
uh we have this one with salmon and
avocado looks nice even though the
options outside of the box look very
like look delicious so I wouldn't go for
the box one uh we have this one with a
poretta which is roasted pork from like
Rome and like the Roman region very very
good and uh yeah if you ever around
there they also do a lot of nice
festivals so check it out uh this one
has poretta and mushrooms and the last
one is this one with the Ian eggplants
we also got salads we have chicken and
uh cheese what looks like greated
parmesan and then we got tuna and feta
with croutons and olives again this is
all you need for a salad the only Caesar
we know here is J Caesar I know that's
bad but actually it's true it's just
very very cliche but it's true like we
don't like sear salad and then we've got
this one it's called pincho we cheed him
uh artichoke sauce and mozzarella okay
interesting shape it looks funny I don't
really know what a Pino is it may be
something from like another Italian
region I'm not so familiar with it
actually to be honest this Ary choke is
a bit of a joke cuz there's not a lot of
it
um let's try it out and
see that tastes like art choke actually
tastes quite natural so very nice yeah
it's not flavoring yeah I like this one
we then have some stuffed croissant
because here we're not we're not French
so we're not scared of putting things in
crants like our friends across the
border so this they're quite similar
this one has curam and scorta it looks
like little salad thing I honestly I
don't really like it doesn't taste like
much and it just ruins everything
visually next cant we have I think it's
the same cheese just with cooked ham
instead in Italy we actually do eat a
lot of savory croissants H sorry people
um we usually eat them as like tiny
bites in like an apparative they serve
them they're like really really this
size they're very tiny we also have this
one which is supposed to be a fuka with
a plant-based
chinito I mean honestly this is not a
fuka I mean quite clearly there's been
some like mistake in the menu uh because
it's just a sandwich and I don't know
why do plant-based things always have
very sad bands like this why why don't
you use this one this looks much nicer
this is like just very sad and plain we
do have some snacks as
well we have some mixed fruits and nuts
we have roasted and salted mix nuts and
then we have cheese snacks okay this
looks like it's um it's a thing cuz
McDonald also has those like tiny
parmesans uh those like tiny parmesan
snacks and Starbucks seems to be
following suit and just giving you some
cheese snacks it just says it's like a
semi hard cheese and it's only made with
three ingredients nice you know milk
salt and ren okay no I'm a bit
disappointed I was expecting actual
cheese like tiny bits of cheese this is
like it's like a
chip yeah they're cheesy they're not too
bad actually moving on to our more
lunchy options this is the grilled
cheese on sourdough the tomato
mozzarella sandwich on Pacha
they also offer a Hamond Swiss on a
baguette and a turkey provolone pesto on
chabata that we did not get I want to
take a bite of this grilled cheese the
bread actually looks pretty good there's
not going to be a cheese Bowl it's going
to crack in half if I do that it's
literally so solid from sitting here all
day okay wait it looks like there's no
cheese even in this that's so weird it
must be like a lighter cheese I've had
way better grilled cheese but this
Bread's actually pretty tasty this
sandwich seems inspired by Italian
flavors so I'm very shocked that it's
not on the Italian menu that is one sad
looking sandwich I'm going to take a
bite from the middle don't be mad it's
just that all the filling has like moved
to the center of the
bread it's not bad it's not great but
it's not a bad sandwich it mostly tastes
like pesto we also have a variety of
protein boxes here we have the PB&J
protein box this used to be my lunch
every single day when I was in college
Starbucks in Italy has a lot of Bakery
options this I'm very excited about cuz
I think we do actually associate
Starbucks with like a Breakfast Cafe in
a way starting from a maple and peon
braid then we have a cinnamon
swirl yeah looks nice and fluffy and
then we've got the saddest saddest
looking crust on ever uh this is the
vegan one it's just like a very
unpleasant Brown is this what the laco
butter makes like just something very
Brown it doesn't feel that great and
like
inside it just
actually it cuts a little bit like a
bread who in a
way right Bread's vegan yeah so some
bread in the shape of a cam and then we
got another cant this one is multigrain
and honey and then we got a plain one
very good lamination actually Starbucks
look there's a lot of lot of layers
actually Starbucks called these
croissants French croissants in Italian
as well um and they actually do look
quite different uh compared to the
Italian croissants that I'm used to
Italian croissants they're not made of
layers of dough and butter let's
see a plain one I will have it only if
it's laminated this way I think the
Italian one is just really meant to be
filled so I'm curious to see how the
others actually look and feel just
because they are still the French ones
but they are filled so we got this one
here with apricot jam let's check it
out yeah lots of Jem looks quite nice
and then we have the green thing here
here in Italy that is not matchup it's
pistachio tastes like a natis spread
quite quite a nice bread there's not a
lot of it though and final one we got
the custard this also looks quite nice
just want to see how much custard there
is in here there's a lot it's a bit eggy
as well which is what I would look for
in a custard
not too lemony just a hint and like a
bit of vanilla and apparently you can
also get a Hazen the cant but we were
not able to get it um and then we have a
double chocolate cookie and a hazelnut
donut yeah we're starting to enter
foreign territory here maybe a bit sad
compared to what's coming after which
are these mini Donuts quite cute and
colorful and then we have some brownies
we have a caramel crumb
Brownie and then we have a triple
chocolate brownie I actually quite like
brownies it's one of those sort of
foreign cakes that uh I'm I'm kind of
very used to and I don't mind having it
let's see it's we do it well here in
Italy this is like the ones I'm used to
that I've had and then we have this one
it's a raspberry and coconut loaf cake
it does look a bit like a typical
Italian cake we I had no idea that this
type of cakes were called loaf cakes but
seems quite accurate not quite convinced
about the stuff on the top it just
doesn't seem necessary I would have put
it inside just to flavor the dough
rather than just put it at the top and
then we have a strawberry cheesecake
then you may also be able to find apple
pie apricot field Rings custard and
raisin swi then a vanilla and chocolate
muffin that's also available in triple
chocolate brownie and orange mini
chocolate muffins carrot cake that can
also be red velvet and chocolate cake
and a milk chocolate gold coin the US
also has a lot of baked goods we have a
couple of the iconic Starbucks cake pops
I want to take a bite of this cookies
and green
one that's so good this is the Blueberry
Scone the everything Bagel the petite
vanilla scone the coffee cake even
though it looks like someone sat on it
it looks a little smushed but it's very
good the incredible incomparable lemon
loaf it's delicious the glazed dut I did
say that Italy's Bagel didn't look that
good not that ours looks any better but
I just want to taste the everything
bagel to see what the flavor is
giving it's like mediocre
it's not that good on flavor and it's
not a great texture I would only reach
for a Starbucks Bagel if I was like
going on a flight or something and this
was just like my only option I don't
think that I would ever purchase it with
a million other good bagel options
around me so the pumpkin loaf and the
pumpkin cream cheese muffin are seasonal
exclusives along with the baked apple
croissant which was not available today
I feel like people are buying them like
crazy they're really good and if you
want the little snacks there are also
these options we got yogurt with Wild
Flour honey and yogurt with berries and
jam then we got some fruits you can also
get pineapple and then we've got just a
fruit salad and finally we've got this
paint the cookie stro so is this how
you're supposed to have it this feels
like something a child will have it's
like I'm alone at home and I'm like 12
I'm having a very calorific drink with
like weird
stro yeah weird
actually don't mind the stro per se but
just the idea seems so
ridiculous we also got a few iconic
Starbucks checkout snacks so this is the
marshmallow dream bar we have the melins
and we also have the vanilla almond
biscotti I see these at every single
Starbucks I go to and I'm always tempted
to buy one I kind of want to try these
melins I don't think I've ever had a
meline
before
that's pretty good it kind of tastes
like a cakey sugar cookie I don't know
if it's supposed to taste like that but
it does taste like that you may also
know Starbucks for the Starbucks Reserve
roasteries that are very much present in
the US you can also find them in other
countries and actually there's one here
in Italy too in Milan that open in 2018
and the roasteries are famous for having
different types of coffee that have the
rarest coffee that you can find at
Starbucks they offer experiences at
these roasteries where they demonstrate
different ways to make the coffee
through blending brewing and infusions
and they also have wine beers cocktails
some of which include coffee they have a
lot of food options too each Roastery is
a little different in its architecture
so it's really interesting just to have
a look around unfortunately we were not
able to visit The Roastery in this trip
but we actually went in 2018 so we're
going to play some footage of our visit
I was there we took a visit to one of
the roas here in New York City it was
really cool to see how they make these
different drinks and everything in there
is so fancy compared to a regular
Starbucks these are the drinks exclusive
to the New York Roastery that we wanted
to try let's start with the hazelnut
Bianco latte I love hazelnut
so it's really good it's really really
really good I feel like it tastes better
than any other Starbucks Coffee I've had
let's try the whiskey barrel-aged cold
brew this is intriguing to me I hate
whiskey but there's no real whiskey in
this okay wait it tastes like there is
whiskey in it but there isn't I made
sure to say like alcohol free what I I
think from what I'm understanding is
that they might age this in the whiskey
barrels once the whiskey is removed from
those barrels but it still tastes very
strong spiritree whiskey barrel each
it's spiritfree but the Spirits are
lurking you can still taste it this was
actually invented in Italy and then yeah
launched again recreated other The
Roastery uh this is the oato CAF late
and oato just literally means oil and
it's just the cafe latte with SH of
olive oil apparently um this is the CEO
of Starbucks that traveled to Italy to
CC and just saw some people having shots
of olive oil and coffee and thought it
would be a good idea to roll this out
internationally and for some reason
thought that all Italians were actually
doing it I don't know it's the first
time I hear it like I will be quite
happy to have a shot of olive oil for
Just Energy but I don't know if I would
like it in my coffee that seems like a
bit too much it's like oh what are two
things Italians are associated with
olive oil and coffee let's just put them
all together and make it a drink it's
green
it's greens and now like the oil is
floating on the coffee so the idea is
that they should emulsify but you know
it's been sitting here for a bit cuz
we've been doing all the filming so
perhaps that's why they separated it
just smells like coffee let's try it
out I don't taste much the olive oil
which is okay it leaves you a different
feeling on the lips like the same
feeling that you get when you like bite
into a very oily thing this is the
moment that I've been dreading this
entire day the oato cafe lattes these
are basically lattes with a bunch of
olive oil in them I don't know whose
idea this was it doesn't sound like a
good idea to me but let's see which one
is better iced or not
iced it's not bad I can definitely taste
that there's oil in this but it's not
like aggressively oily in my mouth which
is what I was really dreading it's
really not terrible I think it's the oat
milk that's helping cover up some of
what's happening this looks terrible the
iced latte has completely like separated
so the top is just a layer of olive oil
which means I'm going to get a mouthful
of olive oil upon for
sip it just Tayes like a mouthful of
olive oil let me mix it with a straw and
see if that helps to be clear this
didn't look like this when they first
gave it to us it's just been sitting
around for a while it tastes better but
still mostly tastes like olive oil I
think if I had to get an oato again I
would only get it hot just because it
covers up all the olive oil flavor which
kind of defeats the purpose of getting
one of these but they're not
terrible it's quite hard actually for me
to think that Starbucks is actually
competing with the cafes that you can
find here just because the offer is very
very different like it's the only place
where you can find drinks this size this
elaborate and with this much cream and
like milk and syrups and all this stuff
I would say in general Starbucks is
definitely huge here you can find them
everywhere I feel like you're either a
Duncan person or you're a Starbucks
person and it's very common for a chain
like Starbucks to be somebody's everyday
coffee shop I will say if you live in a
major city with a lot of other options a
lot of different coffee shops you might
not head to Starbucks all the time but
it is one of the more popular coffee
options in places like suburbs it's hard
to say that's popular cuz it is not
really present everywhere uh obviously
it is in Milan Rome and like the big
cities but you won't find it in a
village what we do I'm from like a
mediumsized town in Italy but in the
evening I'll go out to a small town you
know during the day I'll go out for a
day trip in a small town I won't live
there but I will hang around there
that's where you don't find the chains
and I think that is what well you know
still makes Starbucks perceived as
something a bit foreign because you
still don't see it in this tiny towns
and you still see the local cafe like
it's just in general the idea of chain
doesn't really resonate well in terms of
the actual cafees like the long coffees
I don't know actually if they get lots
of orders from like Italians I think you
either just I will either go
personally just for simple espresso or
from the elaborate like for the
elaborate things because because they
are a bit like an ice cream to me treat
yourself but also like if I see you
drinking that cookie crumble mocha frap
at 9:00 in the morning I'm going to slap
it out of your hand grow up please just
the culture of like the big drink to
take away to like drink on the go drink
in your car that's just not that's just
not how things work around here people
really love the Starbucks seasonal menus
I think every year when fall or
Christmas time rolls around everyone
gets super excited to see what new stuff
is on the menu what old stuff is coming
back I mean speaking of the food I think
they've done a very good job sort of
adapting to the Italian you know flavors
um the drinks are a little bit different
U there are some things like cookies and
cream that are just no Italian we all
know that Starbucks is a big American
chain and I think they obviously want to
keep a part of that uh because you know
Italians are curious about it as
well unfortunately Starbucks does not
list uh ingredients on its website we
did try to get in contact but we're
still waiting for a reply the US however
does provide all of the ingredients for
their full menu we thought it would be
interesting to see what's in the oato
range since both us and Italy have this
available the oato cafe latte with oat
milk contains oat milk which is just
water and oats canola oil di potassium
phosphate calcium carbonate tricalcium
phosphate sea salt dicalcium phosphate
riboflavin vitamin A vitamin D2 vitamin
B12 brute espresso which is just
watering coffee and extra virgin olive
oil the exciting thing about this drink
is the addition of extra virgin olive
oil which is mostly associated with a
Mediterranean diet it does ramp up the
calories compared to a normal latte
which with 2% milk is 190 calories but
there's been a lot of research
surrounding the benefits of extra virgin
olive oil particularly around preventing
diseases and decreasing cholesterol plus
the oato latte has been fortified with
vitamins so sounds pretty good to me
even though I'd never order this
again in the US AV ventti caramel
frappuccino is
$6.75 or €6 37 keep in mind that's a New
York price the prices might vary
slightly depending on what state you're
in in Italy a caramel frappuccino is
$570 that translates to roughly
$6.9
so it actually works out cheaper here in
Italy in the US AV ventti cappuccino is
$6.25 or
590 in Italy a venti capuccino is
€340 in dollars that translates into
$369 to be honest they're kind of fair
judging by how big the things are coffee
is always quite cheap actually in Italy
um it's usually around € lately has gone
up a little bit but like if if you pay
150 it's already very expensive again
like I think this goes into idea of like
these drinks are ice creams they're not
coffees because paying 350 like five
it's a lot a lot of money and that's
just not a coffee because the coffee is
supposed to be like quick and cheap